when Julian professor Julian Bond
visited I said yo we had a we
he mentioned you and your kind of
gravitas as a leader and kind of icon
during the civil rights movement and he
told one anecdote that was especially
moving about how during a march that he
was present at the normal type of hate
and and cussing and people throwing
things was was there and was present and
midway through the march you kind of
showed and where they were there and
people so to recognize and kind of
slowed down and and kind of halted their
their kind of attack on the on the march
and you know there's this kind of oh
that's how Harry Belafonte here and I
was kind of wondering how do you deal
with this sort of admiration for your
image while at the same time kind of
facing this this idea of race and this
kind of hate that that was clearly
present there before but you know is
kind of removed with your with your
celebrity status or kind of position of
fame while celebrity is a terrible virus
it exists on so many levels and in so
many ways and the great question about
celebrities it's obvious power and most
people who are touched by celebrity
having one or two choices to self
annoyed to use that celebrity in the
service of the acquisition of more
celebrity or to use that celebrity and
use that spotlight of celebrity and turn
it to focus on something that you think
will enhance the needs of the human
family I find that that kind of service
is far more rewarding and just the
acquisition of more material power or
more wealth or more celebrity I find
that having been given that kind of
recognition and that platform I was
aware that as an artist I had a capacity
to say and to do things that for cause
people to link or just a bit
on any question that might be before
them if a celebrity were handling the
manipulation of how to approach that
question I had to answer that question
and then when I found that there was
that space I found an opportunity to
make a lot of noise and to say a lot of
things and to lead people to places that
might change the way in which I found
them and how do you how do you interact
with with those who who you clearly see
is you know having a sense of a
different sense of race or in some case
a racist mentality but treating you with
a different sort of respect even though
you come from a different background er
how do you how do you engage those who
have this kind of mental blockade in
terms of race and and kind of allow your
celebrity to work through through that
that that sense of hate the racist
characteristic that evidences itself in
America touches everyone we can measure
response by the extent of how this
racist view is applied or acted upon
some people can become very very cruel
very brutal they can take human life
rooted in the extent of their passions
on their racist belief some other people
just move through life in a very casual
way accepting that there exists this
difference in that difference will ever
be bridged they've already shut the door
so when you come up against racism you
have to not first will understand the
level on which it exists how is it being
applied and then you can begin to
dismantle it based upon the tools you
need to help in the process so that if I
meet you and I suspect that you have
some racist thoughts lingering the first
thing I approached you with as a smile
and in that fact if there is such an
friendly overture a lot will be said
about how we get on from the men and how
you handle that smile I learned a lot of
this from my dealings with dr. King the
positive encounter the or can always
meet persons and saraly because so much
of life is filled with adversarial
experience or you can meet people in a
position of adversarial clash or
encounter and choose to take the sting
out of that adversarial behavior how do
you disarm the enemy how do you change
the paradigm how do you shift the mood
how do you take all of us to another
playing field and from that point of
view the chessboard of life is hugely
fascinating to me because I will look
something and see if we have lost ground
or have come upon a cruel moment and
while I may be been born the loss and
the monly the results of such a tragedy
my first inclination is then how do I
fix it how do I beat it I'm coming back
to this course it needs to be dealt with
and then comes that challenge and then
comes the chance to exercise imagination
exercise environmental gifts to bring
things to bear to just make a difference
and I find making it differently every
level of the human encounter is an
important way in which to apply your
tools and your gifts and I can casually
pass you by and leave you undisturbed
without with anything or I can pass you
by and engage you and inform you it's
something you may never known before
that might change the way which you see
me or see the life you live I think it's
how we treat the gift of life to given
all these things of the word to work or
your senses are alive
imagination the capacity to exercise
free thinking to challenge what uh what
those who woulda press you would have
you believed to be the truth or the only
truth or the dogma all these things are
constantly out there and what a
wonderful and counted to be able to just
challenge these things yourself and find
new solution in new ways I cannot
tolerate conformity it defies me
something should be embraced but if I
conform to a negative set of principles
than I'm encouraging that negativity and
enhancing or that oppression my thing is
that wherever I see it I challenge